thank you
for inviting me here it's been a very
interesting experience and a very
diverse workshop today that i really
enjoy
um so
i would like to talk about
something that we've been working on for
a long time it's actually related to the
previous speaker that i
i'm not going to explain the connection
now um but
so the
[Music]
the challenge of uh
trying to
infer
how under how much uh
purifying selection variants are uh
across the genome so uh
trying to uh break these these silos
that we've uh also seen here of uh
uh drilling down from uh uh from what we
think is the most severe um to less and
less severe um
and trying to um
to capture that across a wide range
and um so this is something that that
started quite a while ago uh when i was
a postdoc with jay chanduri and then
continued in my own lab since uh 2017
and yeah
so
the the the question that we are that
we're trying to
address here is if we if we sequence a
genome and we we recover a number of
variants from this this genome
how do we prioritize those that
that might be disease causal that might
have a molecular effect
and
these might be large numbers of variants
that we have to sift through
and uh like i just said this is
our goal was really to to break up this
this these filtering hierarchies
that
that go let's say from nonsense to
canonical splice in this sense splice
region and then slowly into
the regulatory regions and for each of
those have a have a bunch of
individual annotations that they use and
trying to prioritize with these
additional annotations
because i mean these these annotations
are pretty diverse
everyone is using a slightly different
one everyone is using a slightly
different threshold on those and
it is just
[Music]
very very complicated to navigate
so
so we're talking data integration
essentially um so so how could we
integrate these these different
annotations uh on a on a on a
genome-wide level
well if we if we had a training data set
of pathogenic versus benign and if this
training data set was was nicely
distributed across the genome
there would be a very intuitive way of
doing that
and
fortunately we don't have that right we
uh
our the variants that we know the
pathogenic and the benign variants that
we already know they're not evenly
distributed throughout the genome
they're highly clustered they're
they're clustered because of these these
hierarchies that i've shown you but
they're also clustered because of the
way that we've studying genes and for
how long we've been known a certain gene
how well is a gene is conserved whether
it's present in a model organism or not
this all impacts the number of variants
that we've that we find in our clinical
databases
so
just because of that they're not very
well suited to be used
the number of variants in these
databases is growing so so don't get me
wrong so there's
there might be potential for improvement
however
so this is looking at clinvar
and
clinvar still lacks
exon distal variants so this is
a representative
a representation of
variant categories
the ones that we're trying to abolish
across the genome
and this is glenbard
so
in glenvar you find a lot of variants
that are
obviously very close to exons
a lot of
nonsense variants a lot of
missense variants
what you
and this is
there's some variation between the the
clinical labels or the
the variant significance labels that are
in clinvar
but this is
probably even more indication of an
ascertainment bias in this database and
if you if you might wonder uh whether
this has changed at all over the last
years uh it hasn't really so the
representation of non-coding variants
even over just the last few years hasn't
improved in glenvar
okay so
what we did
back in uh i started 2012 then published
2013
is we we decided to use these these uh
human uh
lineage-specific differences that we
partially just discussed in a different
context um so variance that since the
last common ancestor with uh with
chimpanzees or the ancestral genome
sequence if you compare to the the human
reference
positions that have changed
they're about 15 million of these
and you exclude variants that you see uh
let's say in in a thousand genomes at
the time
so you get a nice set of variants that
have uh
um that are
fixed derived in the human reference
or in the in the human population if you
use a thousand genomes additionally
and um
for which you can assume that you've
seen many many generations of purifying
selection
so some of them might be functional but
we would assume they're
a very small minority and the vast
majority is actually uh fixed by uh
thrift and uh
has seen a lot of generations with
purifying selection
and now these variants are actually
spread around nicely throughout the
genome
and we can contrast them with variants
that we
randomly draw so essentially we are
drawing the noble variants with the same
substitution patterns and approximately
a similar variant density in a
in large blocks of the genome and you
can imagine
the result to
look like that and the human derived
alleles the the severe effects are
underrepresented and then you have these
these denoble
variants that you draw and that we
consider proxy deleterious and
you can now use those two as a tooled
labels in your training data set and you
can use those to combine uh various
annotations that you have
and so like i said if we've done that a
while ago and
it is actually
we think very useful because you now get
uh
let's say for a
nonsense variant uh you now have a score
right that ranges from
probably no effect like uh olfactory
receptor
to
high score
neurodevelopmental g
and
[Music]
everything is on the same scale you in
principle don't need to consider
the variant effect category anymore it's
part of the model you're getting a
continuous score with which you can rank
your variants
so has been popular people have been
using it have been citing it
and we have tried to to maintain it over
the years so we
started supporting the new reference
genome put it on a new website
made tools made offline screen tools
available
more recently
we've been trying to address uh
specific limitations so we've been
looking into
whether for example the splice
annotations could be improved that we're
integrating and so we've been using
experimentally available data to to
benchmark um a number of of two words
that
were developed for splice variants
especially also
deep learning models or convolutional
neural nets
that have been used
and
we found that
these are
specifically very useful i mean it's
very similar to what tony has just
talked about with 3d
genome architecture we get a sequence
based model where we can put both
alleles in
and we can calculate a difference a
delta value
um for the um
for the potential change to the to the
genome and we can integrate this data
that is in our model
and there are other specialized uh
models uh becoming available for
utrs and for for regulatory sequences
which i will uh briefly address too
so we can then see that just integrating
these these additional annotations
improves our model performance in these
specific categories
so
you can see here for uh for two
different versions so
here we had included uh just um
uh more static annotations about splice
variants from
uh db
nssv
and then we've been
including
the sequence based models
in this version here and we get another
boost
in the performance for specifically
these sides while
other variant categories are not
impacted by that so if we find a better
annotation
we can put it into our model and we can
integrate it
into our variant ranking
so
in principle you could just continue in
doing that for
all molecular functions or molecular
predictors that you
imagine to work on a genome-wide scale
that are
sufficiently unbiased to be integrated
and yeah it would keep us busy
but there are
also also other things
methodologically that you can do
we've for example looked into
alternative definitions of this training
data sets you can for example also
use uh
actual singleton variants versus
has a proxy for this the sunovo class
with standing variation and you get a
similar model
out of that
yeah
so
i at least wanted to mention so we uh
what we've been looking into over the
the last years uh
uh also these regulatory sequences
which we also heard are very important
and really not the new thing we knew
know that since the 70s that these are
probably underlying
a lot of our
evolutionary
changes
it's a it's a diverse class and we're
sometimes
not very careful in defining what we're
talking about
so i'm specifically now talking about uh
not the bigger class of non-coding
sequences but but regular regulatory
sequences so promoters enhancers
and we've been we've been studying them
with
massively parallel reporter essays
so where you've um
it's similar to in a way a luciferase
essay where you you have some reporter
gene and you're putting the element of
interest with a minimal promoter in this
reporter gene and you're reading out
the activity of this element or the
change of activity depending on which
element you put in there
and so we um
a few years ago we we've done that for a
number of elements
and we've done
in silico
sorry we've done
saturation metagenesis so not the in
silico saturation metagenesis that we
just heard for these these computational
models but actual actually creating all
potential variants along these sequences
and reading them out
and we thought this was a
very interesting exercise because we
were hoping that
it would also tell us about useful
predictors of regulatory function
and and we realize that there's not so
much useful out there at this point
so um one limitation
so a lot of these two words are
prioritizing species conservation pretty
highly
but species conservation is not
necessarily the best predictor
and a lot of
methods
they're they're
good in
inferring repressive
effects from
destroyed motifs but on the other hand
they're not really good in seeing the
creation of
of new
motifs
so
i'm just putting two very brief examples
here so the one is their conservation is
really not very informative so here up
here you're seeing the the variant
effects that we read out and below you
see the
you see some conservation tracks and you
see some
functional predictors
uh
yeah and and then you see annotated
motifs and you see this is not very well
aligned so neither the available motif
data is well aligned with these blocks
where we see the largest effects not in
order we see a a good correlation with
the conservation scores and it highly
depends on the element so this is
another element
where things seem to be
much more
much better predicted by by conservation
but again motifs are
really poorly annotated across these
regions uh so there's a lot to be done
and uh
so this is maybe a bit of a summary here
about the power that you have depending
on what you're looking at
um so this one is the the power that you
have in this sense variance for for
separating pathogenic versus benign
variance versus uh trying to predict uh
regulatory variant effects so there's a
still still a lot to be done
and uh was what the field has been uh
looking at over the last
probably already seven years by now
yeah yeah more um
there
is the um
uh
convolutional neural networks so you're
trying to use sequence and uh
and deep learning models uh to infer
function and we are seeing some attempts
and i think this needs to continue
wherever integrates additional
information into that or um
like histone marks or uh
increases the context that there's a lot
that can be done
and so so actually these these
the sequence based predictors they are
currently performing the best
in these comparisons
with the reporter essays
but again here uh
there seems to be a larger challenge in
developing good models that that also
work across cell types or that are
profiting from
training data in many cell types um
right now we're seeing more of a mean
expression uh
prediction effect if you're if you're
trying to go into
um
integrating data from many cell types
and profiting from the from the data
that's actually there
okay so uh then i would like to switch
over from these rather short variants so
so cad can actually predict
um
or score variants uh
that are single nucleotide variants that
are short intel changes that are
multi-allelic substitutions
but obviously there's a there's a whole
class of much larger variants out there
structural variants and i probably don't
need to give an introduction into those
but
i think the the fun fact that uh
maybe not everyone is yet aware is that
uh if you just look by a number of bases
the fact that they are the the class
uh um that that uh
describes the most differences between
two individuals so um
even though we and this depends on the
study right the first study suggested
that we have about
uh
10 000 structural variants more recent
studies are up to 25 000 structure
variants per individual
so the number is much lower than the
millions of short variants that we were
just talking about but
the impacted sequence might be much
bigger
and so so again the challenge here that
there's not really a good training data
set
um and
so the clinvar data set especially is
very small and very very biased
so we're trying again to to move to a
similar system here
um where we use the the human derived
and the chimpanzee derived variance this
time
to
have a proxy benign data set and we
match that with randomly drawn
uh regions of the same size from the
genome
so here just to
to show you that again that the clinvar
dataset is is really problematic
in gray i'm showing you
the structural variants from
nomad sv
and then in
in the red and orange you see
the clinvar variant so they are much
longer
than the typical variants that you
observe
they're really really close to coding
genes
and they're enriched for helpless
efficiency variants
or hyper insufficiency genes
so
that's why we're trying to get away
right from such variant sets and use
this other data set for training
so it's a very similar system otherwise
to get but a major difference now is you
need to um
to
summarize uh all these annotations
across a wider span and you need to make
some design decisions about what you do
there so you have have a bunch of
annotations
that you can obviously use
but then you need to ask how do i
incorporate them into my model so you
can incorporate them some of them as
distance features so how far are we away
from a tad boundary how far how far away
are we from the next coding exon
but you can also then
incorporate some summary statistics like
what proportion of bases have a cat
score of i don't know about 30. uh
are there um
gerb uh highly conserved regions uh in
this window that got deleted
it's actually a big challenge challenge
for inserted sequences and we are not
solving that uh very well right now for
insertions we're currently just looking
at the immediate genomic context while
what we probably should be doing is
looking more into
predictive models that that use the
sequence
okay so we one featurizes those
and then
puts them into the model um there are
not too many tools out there yet and
we've also been having problems
comparing to the tools that are
available because they're sometimes not
easy to run or cannot even be run on a
new
variant set
um but so the the tool seems to uh
generally work again we try to
to pay some attention to also make it
accessible to have a website where
people can upload their variants have a
tool that they can download
and allowing them to to use that
you can then obviously apply such a tool
and
even just under on the nomad sv data set
you can pull up interesting events that
might be uh
potentially interesting
also from a clinical perspective for
these individuals
um
but so yeah so it works in as it's
supposed to as a as a variant
prioritization tool
um
yeah so
that then also
covers this the second part
so we developed the tool for the for the
present uh
human reference genome we we support all
the assemblies by by coordinate liftover
we
currently don't support inversions in
translocations just because we don't
have any training data for it
um and uh in the future we would really
love to go into uh including the
inserted sequences uh into into the
model
okay uh that's where i'd like to thank
you and open for your questions
[Music]
additional information and sometimes
[Music]
survive so that's just the database that
you're referring to um
yeah i know we
could look into that but we're just
using it as a benchmark at the end of
the day because everyone's comparing to
that
but it's not part of our data
[Music]
structural variants identified in
patients with cancer
that we tried to score it is
deleteriousness it's not the ideal
measure for somatic variation uh
i guess that's where your question is
also heading towards um they
yeah it works to some extent and similar
for for head with four variants
you can apply it for cancer it is not
ideal and the assumptions are not really
meant
and then the second question is
they're fascinating and i was wondering
their their uh all employees correctly i
think
they just people just have to report the
various class but yes there's depending
on the method there's a good amount of
uncertainty about the ends of these
variants and
we had we have made an arbitrary
decision here of using
a 100 base pairs
context
if if the variance is even higher than
that
we obviously have a problem um
the good thing is that i mean the the
methods are also getting better and with
long read sequencing you're getting much
more precise uh breakpoints and more and
more people are actually willing to
identify those functional variants of
that but yeah but very valid point
especially if you look at old
technologies when i try identifying them
the uncertainty might be
in the tens of
you keys out saying clinvar is a bad set
that's um
deleterious variants
correct it is a very
it has a very strong entertainment mind
corrective
negative point
like deleterious
when you need training we need a
positive negative right
so so
you're using meanwhile using who is that
is negative
it's all the better as a positive so if
it used to be nine variants
oh okay
so so instead head is using
the variance that i
[Music]
are fixed in these species so there's
let's say there's an insertion into the
chimpanzee genome okay um
that was not in the common ancestor of a
human chimpanzee yeah then it's part of
our training data center there's a
deletion
that's denied yeah because it has fixed
within the last six million years and oh
that's yeah
yeah so for the structural variance it
was really just random uh for the for
care for short variants it is
same substitution patterns
and
also
considering varying density across the
genome
and we've and you've seen that so you
can
you can replace the original cad
training data set
by using single quotes
let's say from topment or nomad
and uh contrasting that with let's say
variants above one percent of the
frequency works as well so you can do
that so we've done that
and
you get about a similar size training
data
you